- We don't know exactly what causes love.
Love is a mysterious thing as we know
and how many plays have
been written about love,
poems or books.
(instrumental music)
A person doesn't sleep, he doesn't eat,
and becomes fixated or obsessed
with another person.
When it gets as severe as a disorder,
it's very debilitating.
Obsessions.
(instrumental music)
- [Narrator] Our expert
psychiatrist, Dr. Carol Berman
explores obsession in the brain
with the help of the new
Hulu original, Chance.
- Obsession is when a person
has persistent thoughts
about anything and they
keep thinking about it
over and over again,
as opposed to compulsions,
which are actual behaviors
where a person does something
over and over again.
- Mind keeps going back to Afghanistan.
Man does like his scalps.
- Let's say you have to
arrange all the spoons
in your drawer in a certain way
and it takes you like three hours,
and then punish yourself with thoughts
like oh I'm bad, I did this wrong,
I did this wrong, I did this wrong
and the person is trying to fight it
and they can't even get
out of the apartment.
(instrumental music)
I had one patient who was
obsessed with her girlfriend
and she kept going after her,
so erotomania is a little different
and might be more
exciting because it has a
sexual erotic element,
which is more exciting
than arranging your spoons
in the drawer (laughing)
but erotomania is when a person
fixates on another person,
constant emails to the person,
telephone calls, stalking the person,
dreaming about the person.
- Jaclyn.
Jaclyn.
(dishes clattering)
- They could become depressed from it
or the person could be enraged,
so angry because the erotic object
doesn't return their love.
- He told me
how it would be
if I tried to leave.
- In any medical field, if
you get very emotionally
involved with the patient,
you won't be able to help the person.
We can't step outside the boundaries
because people have done these things
and terrible results have happened.
Patients sometimes kill
themselves if the doctor starts
hanging out with them or
trying to have sex with them,
and the restrictions are very severe.
- I want to help you,
I'm trying to help you.
I care about you.
- A lot of psychiatrists
will go for therapy.
I've had doctors come to
me and try to, you know,
stop erotomania or stop
obsessive compulsive disorder.
We want to make sure we're okay.
We're dealing with
mental patients everyday
so some of us are not okay.
Maybe we don't start okay or
why do we go into the field
in the first place.
- Familiar with the
concept of the Frozen Lake?
Something you want so badly,
but go out to the center
of Frozen Lake to reach it.
- Where the ice is thinnest.
- But you won't see that.
- We're just at the beginning
of learning about the human mind.
Some people, you know, we
could work on them for years
and we can't get rid of
the obsessive thoughts.
It's always a challenge to figure out
how to take care of them.
(dramatic music)